vous amenez une brique de lait je vous
ai mené une brique de l'aisne et cette
brique de l'aele et s'appelle elle
s'appelle c'est qui le patron et le
patron c'est le consommateur
emmanuel vasseneix est venu à la
rescousse de 50 familles d'agriculteurs
au bord de la faillite par conviction il
a créé avec eux c'est qu'ils battront
une marque qui remettent en cause le
pouvoir absolu de la grande distribution
son objectif convaincre les
consommateurs de payer plus cher un
produit de qualité rémunérant
correctement les producteurs on se
retrouve le site septembre 2016 a pour
nouvelle avec une dizaine de producteurs
dépité et le patron ces conducteurs qui
s'appelle martial darbon qui est un
grand ami dit un moment sur le nex le 11
novembre on n'aura plus les moyens de
payer et toutes les familles que vous
voyez là c'était une certaine
cinquantaine de familles eh bien on va
mettre la clé sous la porte
il me dit ça comme ça
[Musique]
martial darbon et président élu de la
coopérative bresse val de saône avec ses
collègues producteurs de lait il doit
faire face à une crise agricole sans
précédent en pleine confiance avec leurs
partenaires emmanuel vasseneix ils vont
désormais s'engager sous la marque c'est
qui le patron à l'ambiance était
catastrophique parce que nous on a vu
une situation qui était dramatique ont
gagné pas notre vie manger de l'argent
tous les jours et puis enfin pour ma
pomme quand vous êtes responsable d'un
groupe de savoir que vous emmenez le
groupe dans le vide ou dans le mur pas
simple à pass à me le faire des nuits
qu'on peut bien détendu compliqué la
marque c'est qui le patron est soutenue
par les consommateurs devenus des
consom'acteurs elle garantit les
produits sans ogm et des prix de vente
qui rémunère correctement les
agriculteurs 20 millions d'unités vont
être écoulés sur une année comme une
traînée de poudre
la marque va s'emparer d'autres produits
conditionnés jus de pomme de farine ou
bien vains et miel
l'aventuré gagne l'europe en espagne la
marque qui n est celle reffait est déjà
bien implanté aujourd'hui en bresse nous
il ya quatre-vingts personnes qui ont
été sauvés de cette misère noire
et puis maintenant il y en a d'autres
qui évoluent le prix s'améliore chez eux
donc qui qui ont davantage qu'ils sont
mieux rémunérés elle n'était pas en
danger avant ce que l'entreprise
vasselle rémunérer ses producteurs
correctement mais elles ont encore passé
un palier c'est à dire qu'elles sont
encore mieux rémunérées voilà donc il ya
ces 80 familles ici sont sortis de la
moise complètement et puis les il ya une
croissance au niveau des producteurs
degrés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu prends pas de risques de travailler
des gens qui sont prêts à partager qui
avait une folle envie de travailler se
dire parce que un toit du coupé la poire
en deux matches c'est un moins manger à
moitié quoi t'as rien à manger ta rien à
manger
d'accord c'est bien de se goinfrer de
temps en temps mais si après l'espace
d'où tu manges poids et à celle aux
moyens quand même mais qui permet de
prendre la main et de dire on y va
ensemble il ya pas mal donc pas y aller
ensemble
moi je vois là j'ai un immense respect
pour soi pour ça alors c'est vrai qu'à
rage de créer suffit pas si vous avez
voté un créateur imaginaire le plus le
plus génial possible si derrière vous
avez pas là la logique du respect de
l'autre de respect de l'humanité de
respect du commerce de respect de la de
l'autre delà de ça soit du fournisseur
de la bande et ben ça s'arrête là le
marketing à l'ancienne pour moi il est
mort hier qu'aujourd'hui les gens c'est
qu'ils me disent on a fait des études et
puis ça va se passer comme ça etc
je pense que c'est fini c'est
aujourd'hui le pouvoir revient aux vrais
gens c'est aux consommateurs aux
citoyens aux salariés aux producteurs de
lait et au consommateur parce que on a
une force formidable c'est qu'on a on a
on a une carte bleue nous dans la main
c'est ça c'est l'acte d'achat avec vous
on a individuellement la responsabilité
et on a individuellement le pouvoir
d'acheter ou ne pas acheter de ce
produit de sauver ou ne pas sauver une
exploitation et je crois que c'est cette
révolution là qui est en marche
[Musique]